hello my name's Alex Bateman take your
origami DNA template and turn it over so
the white side is upwards then fold the
paper in half be careful to make the
creases accurately and to make the
creases strong use your fingernails
don't fold along this thick line but
turn the paper over we're going to fold
along this thin line be careful to make
the crease accurate and using your
fingernails make it firm then unfold the
paper and make the next crease keep
working away along
then when you're about halfway along
it's easier if you turn the paper round
and start again at the beginning
now turn the paper over and we're going
to fold the diagonal creases fold along
the thin line carefully and accurately
fold along the crease line and make sure
that the crease doesn't extend into the
white border and then unfold and then
move on to the second crease
and continue until you get to about
halfway along and then you can turn the
paper round start at the beginning again
now we're going to fold the white edge
down
this reveals the letters of the DNA code
this is a long crease so take your time
to make sure it's accurate turn the
paper over and we're going to fold the
white edge down again
partly unfold decrease that you've just
made then turn the paper over and repeat
the helix is already starting to form
now turn your hands and we're going to
twist the model and push the two ends
together be brave now we just have to do
a little bit of tidying up of some of
the creases we'll move around the edge
gently making sure all the creases are
nicely formed here's one that's not
quite right
we'll just flatten that carefully and
continue on around the model now DNA is
a double helix so when we finish this
side we have to go back up the other
side again gently flattening all the
creases
you're almost done now all that's left
to do is let go of the model and let
your origami DNA form
Oh
you